there's a little bit of a disconnect
between cosplayers that have been in the
community all along and then the people
that are like oh it's hot birds in
costume that's not quite what it is but
thank you
I think sexy cosplay for me is really
made me confident actually and empowered
me and anything that I do a lot of
people assume that if other people do
sex the cosplay therefore I should also
do sexy coffee I I think it's really
empowering women of all shapes and sizes
to go out and costly it can take me up
to the year maybe multiple years to make
certain costumes and like it doesn't get
as appreciated as somebody that puts the
boots out so that's a little bit
frustrating cosplay was once a way to
express fandom has it turned into a
light driven culture with the hyper
sexualized focus where do we draw the
line on empowerment versus exploitation
in today's influence or different world
and who are we doing it for
I spoke with four women in the cosplay
community to get their tape era meeting
up with Angie today in downtown LA we're
gonna go walk around to some of her
favorite fabric stores and she actually
Commission's costumes for other
cosplayers and she creates them for
herself
usually cosplays Elsa from frozen so I'm
very excited to meet this clean
cosplay is a very personal form of
self-expression for people you know a
lot of us are drawn to it when we're
very young and were drawn to it because
we're sort of insecure in our own skin
and I was desperate for somewhere I
could be accepted and be who I really
wanted to be to me I don't understand
the point of dressing up as a character
if you're not really going to like
become that character I'm constantly
working on multiple things like it's
very rare that I'm specifically just
working on things for myself I'm a
social media impacting cosplay
social media definitely Orient's more
towards the sexy stuff and the boudoir
stuff and you know the skin tight
spandex outfits and those are the people
that have found that they can make a
living on patreon selling photos of
themselves dressed as popular characters
in their underwear that image is what
has become sort of synonymous with
cosplayers
a lot of people who are new to the
community are now seeing that and going
oh okay well if I want to be a cosplayer
I have to start a patreon and do boudoir
I think it's created a sort of toxic
atmosphere it's become very competitive
it's become very sexualized it's become
very antagonistic it can be very
frustrating for the cosplayers that
don't focus on that you know I've
learned a lot about myself and my own
strengths and weaknesses through
dressing up as characters that I relate
to dressing up as Elsa has brought me
out of my shell like I never thought was
possible
why alpha I have a sorted relationship
with my sister we've we've had our ups
and downs there was a distinct moment in
our lives where I started to kind of
resent her and push her away I went to
see frozen and the moment where Elsa
hits Anna when they're kids with dice
blasting and hits her in the head it
struck me very heavily the reason for
that is when I was about six years old
my sister and I were playing outside
while our family was moving there was
this little boy who lived across the
street and my
I wanted to go and I was like okay well
we've crossed the street enough times
like I know how to do it so we just make
sure we look both ways and then I'll
tell mom that you went over to go play
with him so this woman blasted through
the stop sign and my sister went flying
and she cracked her skull so they kind
of pushed me to the side and nobody
really told me what was going on nobody
told me if she was gonna be okay what I
never told anyone I thought it was my
fault I thought that everyone blamed me
the thing that really struck me about
that movie was seeing on his journey and
her struggle of trying to connect with
her sister and cosplaying Elsa is very
special to me because it's a way of
acknowledging how far my sister and I
have come and it's sort of my badge of
honor and and pride
what's one of the biggest changes that
you've seen it gets all about a mod they
did a group to look more like a model a
lot of it that I see is very sexual
Misha Mach makes a living as an artist
selling prints custom masks and other
items she creates from scratch on her
Etsy page cosplay mainly has her own
character hound master leashes found a
way to make cosplay a full-time
profession what is so interesting about
Misha to me is that you're an artist you
create new cosplay but you also don't
try to wait from doing boudoir
I feel like within our society the idea
of sexuality is very taboo which I don't
think it should be it's very natural so
you don't think boudoir a particularly
hast to be super sexual but I do
understand the lack of clothing within
our society feels sexual but I think we
should open our mind up a bit to the
idea of it there's a whole art form to
it that I don't think people quite see
but like the modeling aspects
specifically with your body of every
movement to get the right angle is very
interesting patreon is really flipped it
because there's a lot of people that are
like model styles that are making a lot
of money off of it and how do people use
it the idea that people can subscribe to
you either by project or as a monthly
basis cosplayers do monthly and they can
do different tiers and they get
different rewards some of them have like
private snapshot tiers where you can see
sexier things and then I know some
builders that do PDF files of how their
build was made I specifically kind of
mix everything as always you can be
multiple things and it's okay don't want
to express that and still be an artist
like that doesn't change it it's
wonderful truthfully our world sees so
much sex all the time and like if women
want to empower themselves with
something that's kind of sexual like
they should do it
did you ever feel the pressure to do it
more because the way the trends of
cosplay are turning if I didn't like it
I just wouldn't do it right I enjoy it
like I think with cosplay and modeling
you definitely have to look at me more
sexy if you just want to do modeling the
culture is a very sexual culture it
started for men drawing sexualized women
so you I don't know like some people are
really against a sexualized culture but
it but it's how it started it started
with men drawing sexualized women but
there's definitely ways to do
professional cosplay and not have to
show skin if you like you could be a
builder and I know a lot of people that
do building full-time to me it was
always about fun and craftsmanship but
now they're making one of the believable
stuff the process itself like as painful
as it is it's so much fun I don't think
people know how talented some of these
cosplayers are psy is a professional
cosplayer who builds and sells
accessories like Batman Cal's and
shields for other cosplayers with her
husband Dakota through their small
business meeting while cosplaying DC
characters at Six Flags the to find it's
hard to turn their passion into a
livelihood you know he's more of a
perfectionist I love crafting so much
but it's to a point where like I can't
and beyond that level but I think we
balance each other out pretty well and
we'd never get anything do you have any
thoughts on like what you like her doing
best I push her a little bit more than
she's comfortable with because I know
ultimately what's gonna get views and
followers she doesn't go Oh loot haven't
gone down the rabbit hole yet it was
like the only thing to be seen nowadays
is to either do something the best to do
it lewd or to be the first person to do
it
[Music]
it's so much fun as a hobby but it's
interesting when you take out into a
professional level and then there's like
a lot of pressure behind it to do lewd
things like when I was trying to move
into more professional like we both
could clearly see what that would be
like so I actually started out on
cosplay actually as an actor and I did
theme park work as Wonder Woman and I
very much fell in love with her and this
is back before where no one was cool
when Wonder Woman the movie came out the
lewd Wonder Woman came out and it hurt
to look at I think social media is
putting a lot of pressure on cosplayers
to be more lewd like who's gonna want to
look at it fully clothed superhero one
ones right next to them it's like
nothing see them grow from being
Supergirl into being like Supergirl
without shirt on Supergirl on a thong
super girls holder tips and things
they're chasing something that I'm not
chasing they're chasing those likes does
put a lot of pressure on people because
it's like I'm not gonna get those likes
if I don't do that I'm not a spring
chicken anymore but like I've noticed
that the younger community coming in
there's not that transition of like
growing up and like figuring out like
what you're comfortable doing they just
think that like the way you get views as
you come into it like just basically
naked you're making a decision when
you're 19 who those pictures never go
away but is it still cosplay oh I get in
an argument a lot about that because I
think you're in lingerie not pikachu
ears on no that's technically not
cosplay it's more like a theme to
launder issue the reason why I don't go
to Lotus because it's not gonna get me
anywhere but I'm gonna be in like 15
years like just an older lady like
please join my patreon like I don't
think people think these through what's
one of the biggest changes that you've
seen since you started people are doing
it as much for fun yeah people think
that you do it for attention
or there's a lot of like oh you're just
doing this for your followers and you
should do like really sexy photos and
sell all these like videos and like
things like that
[Music]
Tina's an amateur cosplayer who's just
starting out as a newcomer I wanted to
talk with her about how she's navigating
some of the difficulties that the other
cosplayers had laid out for me I just
started this year I had two or three
jobs working all the time seven days a
week and being the background being a
server I don't really put anything out
as a server but with cosplaying and
Instagram it just feels like oh my god
I'm actually doing something and people
are actually like watching me and paying
attention to like every little detail if
you could be a cosplayer and influence
sort of what would you be probably an
influencer it is a lot of hours a lot of
time but it I mean it's for me it's
worth it but I'm glad that there's
actually people watching and enjoying it
and actually clicking through and
watching my videos this is just a great
feeling that there's actually someone
like oh my god that's so cool you know
you'll have like feeling conventions are
posting just to respect cosplayers pasta
it's not consent that's been burning
around a lot like when I took hostages
behind the mask as a person like me have
feelings just as the me to movement
responded to issues of sexual violence
and assault the cosplay is not consent
movement came out of a need for
awareness for safety and in some cases
security for the players in the
community I think some people get the
idea that maybe it's like oh you're in
costume I can come up and I can like
touch your waist put my hand on your
shoulder but there should be a consent
aspect of like coming up being like can
I take a picture with you instead of
taking a picture you ask and then it's
like can't I put my arm around your
waist can I pick you up
if someone's in costume they don't owe
you anything
you have to ask him for a picture and
you cannot touch them you cannot like
you know it's just being decent to human
being because it's like you no longer a
human being when you're in a costume
the typical convention attendee is
fairly immature kind of socially awkward
a lot of those people have a difficult
time separating fantasy from reality and
then you get the people who like have
been sexually fantasizing about some of
these characters and they want to hug
you or kiss you or touch you in certain
ways that you don't want to be touched
by someone you've just met for the first
time and I've I've had it happen to me
I've had it happened to friends like
we've there are guys who can't
understand that a girl is just being
polite and all of a sudden they're
following you around the convention and
they're trying to get your phone number
and they're finding you at the bar the
restaurant that you're at later that
night and trying to join your table
stalking you on social media until I try
and be your best friend or get a date or
whatever it is the cosplay is not
consent movement came out of a desire to
communicate to people that like those
are not acceptable ways to interact with
cosplayers the issue of consent comes up
in the cosplay world and it's come up a
lot in social media and in feminism I
spoke to doctor and professor she
returned to get more insight on how
social media and hyper sexualized
content plays into female empowerment
today when it comes to hash tag me too
sexual assault sexual violence towards
women and girls it is as we know never
about what she's wearing
women are assault
when they're wearing sweatpants and
veils and running clothes and so consent
is never about what she's wearing like
why can't a woman just be sexy being
herself or being powerful or being smart
ultimately I don't think that putting
laundry on is empowering you know just
being like a true general person being
you know respectful to yourself and if
that's how you respect yourself that's
empowering for me
embracing my sexuality and embracing my
body is part of confidence so having
characters like the Dark Phoenix who as
she grows and becomes more confident her
outfit gets more skin tight and more
revealing
but like it's to me I see it as
empowering I think it's different for
everybody sometimes I think wearing less
clothing feels empowering in certain
ways and sometimes whirring more
clothing feels empowering but with the
whole patreon movement there's a giant
group of cosplay women that are doing
like a very sexy like boudoir shoots and
selling them and it's like the first
movement of women fully owning it
because we had stuff like that with like
playboy but Playboy's owned by men and
there's like a tear down system and then
the woman's the model were like this the
woman's the model she chooses a
photographer she chooses what she wears
and she chooses how she poses and it's
like I think for that is super
empowering that we have like this female
take over on those concepts ever since I
came into the cosplay community it's
always been that way a lot of cosplayers
and lingerie or whatever I try not to
get into that like creepy photographer
asked me you want to do nude so I'll pay
for it or whatever I'm just like no if
it wasn't working out for you do you
think you'd ever cross that line and get
sexier um if it's in a classy way maybe
but that's still a questionable I still
have to really
think about that the women in cosplay
who want to express themselves in hyper
sexualized ways or in revealing ways or
in sexy ways are entitled to do that as
they see fit the problem is when that
becomes the one Avenue for success
because it excludes so many other
possibilities for human expression and
it reinforces very narrow stereotyped
gendered tropes about what it means to
be female in this world but if we fall
into those stereotyped expectations than
people can demean us they can think that
we are less capable or that that's all
we're capable of at the same time if we
don't go along with that program so to
speak then we might not even have
opportunities for visibility or to have
platforms at all so we're damned if we
do present ourselves sexually and
redeemed if we don't present ourselves
sexually with so much to unpack it
became clear the only way to fully
understand the issues at hand was to go
to a con and dress up myself though I
barely know where to begin
it's gonna be SuperDuper fine okay so
I'm doing black cat how do you figure
out how to do the makeup for these
things okay so I try to think about who
that character is and their personality
and how they would dress you have to act
route today I tell new cosplayers that
you really should think in character is
when people ask you for a photo
everybody is different and everybody
cosplays different you know no two
people are ever gonna look the same even
if they're wearing literally the exact
same costume I think that's one of the
important things for us as cosplayers to
remember because you know we do get a
little competitive sometimes and we like
to compare ourselves to other people and
the fact of the matter is we're all
different people when we're all
interpreting these characters
differently I just feel like the stakes
are so much higher for some reason guys
can't find me today
don't go looking what do you think the
most common misconception about
cosplayers is that we're a bunch of
socially awkward losers they should get
a life and we're all just a bunch of
nerds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
people are definitely looking and that's
a weird feeling for me like I you know
you don't notice when people are looking
at you most of the time but like now I'm
like very very aware of it and it's a
little intimidating okay there's no
pressure here it's the beauty of the
small cons is the power of Angie though
and they're like extreme levels of
confidence I just want everyone to
experience it and understand how freeing
and how much confidence it can build by
just embodying a character and having
fun and sharing that phantom with other
people
husband your black cat was super cool
she's fun she's sexy she's romantic but
yeah there were elements to being out on
the con floor and full spandex that were
a little uncomfortable like when you see
a kid walk by or when you have the guy
look at you the wrong way or when
someone asks you why don't you have any
underwear lines it's like oh that's not
something you would usually ask someone
we're gonna awesome pose so I can see
where some of these issues would come up
and be masked and be difficult to tell
if it's something that makes you
uncomfortable or not really hard for us
as adults to unlearn messages that we've
gotten since we were born or even before
we were born and those messages are very
gendered and they tend to be very binary
where boys are taught to climb build
explore fall down pick themselves up and
go on and girls are generally taught to
adorn themselves to be in relation with
others to be pretty so it's not really
possible to think that we're gonna just
emerge as a 22 year old and poop those
messages are gone
women lose value the older they get no
matter what like they don't see
experience look at you they just see the
age and that's unfortunate because men
don't have that pressure like I can play
both sides I'm a strong feminist we
should put women in realistic clothing
but I also understand the fantasy aspect
I think if we lost all of the beauty of
costuming that would be sought to issue
was not with the people who do the work
but the broader systems in society that
say here is this narrow box about what
it means to be female or what it means
to be successful and that narrow box has
to do with conventional Beauty
hyper-sexualization
self objectification none of those
things in and of themselves are wrong
but when we don't have broader options
really limits everyone I have a lot of
work to do but I mean I work on my page
every day so if I just keep continue
doing that for five years or so or even
a year I
I'm pretty sure my page will grow and
ill get there if it doesn't work out
there's always a plan B what is Plan B I
have no idea most of us came to cosplay
because we felt like social outcasts you
know we felt uncomfortable in our own
skin and we utilize cosplay to learn who
we are I feel absolutely indestructible
like I can take on the world when I'm
dressed as one of my favorite characters
[Music]